really we've got to talk about this
dress right off the back you're looking
pretty in pink very 80s what inspires us
I think the Summer of Love I feel like
soon as I think of the 80s and the
summer I think pink and vibrant colors
and I wanted to have a great time and so
this is why yes Emre das a completely
embodies my my vision look you guys are
both rocking the pink tonight we didn't
even plan that but it works because
she's in like the dress and pants that's
reminding me of your 80s montage scene
how much fun was that for you that was a
lot of fun I mean we I think we shot
that over the course you know what like
I think two days but it was really fun I
mean whatever you saw on screen is what
really happened we were playing really
loud music Cyndi Lauper Madonna and we
had the best time we played music we got
in the mood and all the laughter that
you see between Billy and I took all
genuine fun that we're having especially
filming with your best friend it's kind
of it's really easy
what was your favorite fashion outfit
that you tried on the one I keep the one
I keep on for the rest of the season
[Music]